all right so this wasn't going to be the
scheduled video for today I really
didn't have any plans of doing this but
I logged on quite early in the morning
and decided to go ahead and check out GE
tracker now if I go ahead and move on
over there
as you guys can see up here amethyst
bolt tips apparently the offer price is
1 GP the sell price is 135 now if you
know anything about amethyst bolts that
shouldn't be right and on top of that
the sell price is closer to 70 whenever
I check this a second ago so I decided
to hop on over and see if I could
actually buy any of these now I thought
I was only gonna be able to buy a couple
I was wrong so if we're over here now I
have 44,000 I've been asking people my
CC to buy them I also have a couple of
other accounts that I've been buying
them on and I'm literally about to make
absolute Bank by getting fletching XP so
as you guys can see I'm gonna go ahead
and buy them on another account if I in
step I won right now it is still 63 GP
which means this guy whoever it is has
just he has a boatload of them he has an
insane amount of amethyst bolt tips that
he just apparently doesn't want to
fledge and he wants to sell so I'm
willing to buy them all and just go
ahead and Fletch as many of them as I
can and show you guys how much I'm about
to make because this is going to be
absolutely ridiculous because these
prices obviously way below what they
should be I mean look at that the big GE
guide price is 239 lat
Anna this bolt tips will be or I guess
the broad bolts themselves if I mean
look at that
282 I only have to buy another broad
bolt which means I'm gonna be paying
like 120 GP per one I'm making 160 GP
per arrow that I'm about to do I have
44,000 this is about to be ridiculous
and there we go so we have all of the
bolt tips and all the broad bolts so we
are going to need yeah look at that man
I'm gonna give a shout out to a gsx
thanks for helping me buy this stuff man
but on top of that yeah I just had to go
and spend just banks trying to get
people to buy me this stuff it
definitely seemed really sketchy and so
I had to do a lot of convincing but here
we are 118 km/h / - oh we definitely got
all that that guy was trying to sell as
far as how much I paid per bolt
basically as far as everything is
concerned
broad bolts should be about 61 GP and
this bolt should be 63 GP but I ended up
paying probably about 71 to 72 per one
so if we go ahead and take 71 times 2
that's pretty much what I paid for both
the broad bolts and the amethyst bolts
combined now we multiply that times 118
1 1 1 which is how many we have that
means I spent sixteen point seven mil to
get these now overall that's obviously a
lot of money and it took me a little bit
of time probably 40 minutes or so but it
wasn't that bad and alls I had to do was
sit there the GE and just kind of type
every now and then as far as what I can
sell these for though this is where you
guys are probably gonna be blown away
and I am too I don't know why this guy
ever sold them this low but amethyst
bolt tip 280 GP per one so yeah cost me
sixteen point seven mil if it's 280
times oh sorry I don't want to put that
extra one GP in there 280 times 1 18 1 1
1 the a 33 point yeah
33 bill and I paid 16 so I'm about to
make 17 mil hopefully now obviously it's
gonna take a while for these things to
sell same as this bolt tips aren't
exactly or I guess amethyst bolts aren't
exactly the most popular buy but I'm
gonna see how long it takes me and we're
about to make 15 mil and however long
118 cable bolts takes all so I guess
it's good to note that at the beginning
of this I am 84 fletching it was kind of
working I getting fletching up so I'm
quite happy with that I mean in total
this is going to be a ton of XP but if
you guys just want to see how much I get
right away you can do that and then yeah
hundreds of 10 G oh my 10 XP per one I'm
about to be getting one point to my like
oh I didn't even know that that's
ridiculous Jesus all right well I got to
get going and here we go here's the
final hundred so I did space this across
three accounts what I ended up doing was
I found out that that was going to take
me away too long
I over there I guess I underestimated
how long this was going to take it's you
know close to four hours if you do it on
just one account however I just had this
account right here which is obviously my
main from a long time ago small XP lamp
that I was doing it on I also had a
friend's account that I was also doing
them on so I mean overall it took me a
little under an hour and a half to be
able to do all these bolts which is
pretty insane considering obviously I do
have three accounts so it's going to be
faster but even then an hour and a half
and I was able to make
sixteen mill that is so ridiculous so
yeah in total I spent a hundred forty on
these as you guys saw sixteen point five
mill and then I can sell them for around
med price which means I'm selling these
for thirty three mil in costs me sixteen
and a half now obviously if you're doing
this on one account as I said before you
know I would have made sixteen and a
half mill in four hours however I did it
in an hour and a half so obviously this
isn't something that you can replicate
now I mean you can replicate it to an
extent these things are profitable at
times depending on how often people buy
and sell it and obviously at times they
can be really profitable because the
whole reason that I was able to buy
these is because amethyst bolt tips
aren't bought and sold that often so if
someone has a lot of them that they want
to sell quick they're gonna be willing
to sell it for really low now is anyone
ever going to sell that many for 63 GP
again I don't know I think I kind of
just had one of these once-in-a-lifetime
moments at least in regards to amethyst
bolts where I was able to make a ton of
money off of it so hopefully you guys
enjoyed seeing me make all this money it
definitely is a rarity within the game
and I'm very happy that I was able to
capture it on video for you guys so
hopefully you guys enjoyed if you guys
did make sure to leave a like if there's
anything you wanna tell me comment it
down below if you enjoy my content make
sure you subscribe to the channel and on
top of that hope you guys have a
wonderful day and peace